violet potes on est là pour ce nouvel as
qu à ce qu numéro 5 on va répondre à
l'une de vos questions qu'est ce que
c'est l'ouverture d'esprit et comment
être ouvert d'esprit sinon je pourrais
être vidéo sur l'île à merci être ouvert
d'esprit c'est une expression qui
d'ailleurs n'est pas uniquement
française puisqu'on dit en anglais to be
open mind parce qu'on veut dire à quel
point cette expression a du sens bref
c'est une expression mais si on cherche
dans le larousse
on voit que l'ouverture d'esprit c'est
l'attitude à comprendre des questions
diverses et nouvelles et à admettre des
points de vue opposés
donc lhi a non seulement une des
tolérances mais c'est une des tolérances
améliorée puisque jusqu'à comprendre les
autres et non seulement les à m dans un
premier temps avant de prendre en compte
ces partis compréhension on va pouvoir
parler simplement tolérance je pense que
plus simple d'abord cette voir ce que ce
n'est pas un peu lance-pierre son
origine dans les instincts les plus
primaires de l'homme instinctivement on
a peur et on rejette ce qui est
différent nous et de notre tribu et ça
peut être beaucoup de choses comme un
mode de vie une religion une couleur de
peau
voilà donc on voit le monde à travers le
prisme de sa qualité d'origine c'est
souvent inconscients comme phénomène
d'ailleurs et c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'ethnocentrisme s'est notamment
développée par claude lévi strauss et
c'est ce qui nous pousse à penser que
notre communauté d'origine est supérieur
aux autres
mais cette notion de supérieur est très
importante car en fait elle implique que
tout ce qui est différent et vu comme
inférieures bref vous connaissez
l'égocentrisme de fait se mettre au
centre de tout eh bien laissons
centrisme c'est se mettre m on est ni sa
société sa culture au centre de tout
donc la tolérance à l'aide de se défaire
un peu de ce prisme là est d'accepter et
ne comprendre qu'on puisse voir la vie
selon d'autres principes ce qui explique
que l'intolérance est souvent lié à
l'ignorance on ne connaît pas donc on a
peur donc pour aux gets et si on a les
clefs de la réponse qu'on la seconde
partie la question mais on verra ça
après alors c'est quoi exactement la
différence avec l'ouverture d'esprit
quelqu'un ouvert d'esprit va faire un
effort de compréhension
c'est à dire qu'il veut pas sain
le monde à accepter la différence
d'autrui et ne la voir que comme
différence et non il parle de
l'intériorité par exemple mais il va
aussi comprendre cette différence là
c'est à dire qu'il va pouvoir changer
son repaire ethnocentrique l'espace d'un
instant pour reprendre un évènement hors
essence et celui qui comprend à quel
point les caricatures du prophète
peuvent heurter les musulmans et là on
parle bien de comprendre comprendre ce
n'est pas être d'accord avec ne pas être
d'accord avec moi ça ça vient plus tard
la première étape c'est de comprendre
l'ouverture d'esprit c'est donc d'avoir
cette démarche systématique et on
comprend toute une société qui a ses
membres ouvert d'esprit fonctionne
beaucoup mieux puisqu'elle comprend les
intérêts mutuels de ses membres ça fait
beaucoup de fois le mot comprendre je me
rends compte en parlant mais c'est pour
vous compreniez bien de tous voilà donc
tu vas l'ouverture d'esprit est donc je
disais non seulement important
d'apprendre du société mais en plus elle
est importante d'un point de vue
personnel car c'est en se finalement
confrontant à des idées à d d'autres
idées d'autres perspectives que les
siennes que l'on peut espérer s'élever
et affiner ses idées maintenant une
question que l'on peut se poser sur la
tolérance c'est jusqu'où il doit aller
mais ça ça fait forcément penser à la
citation de voltaire je ne suis pas
d'accord à ce que vous dites mais je me
battrai pour que vous puissiez le dire
qu'il n'est pas du tout de lui et qui va
même à l'encontre de sa pensée la
citation est les deux épines des
actrices paul c'est un écrivain anglaise
une écrivain anglais ferment qui a mis
des guillemets alors qu'elle n'aurait
pas dû bref passons d'anecdotes
pourquoi voltaire n'était pas d'accord
avec saab pour des raisons fait très
proche de celle de poppers qui nous
parle du paradoxe de la thaïlande qui
dit que la tolérance limité doit mener à
la disparition de la tolérance en rose
qui dit c'est que si on tolère tout
alors on va même jusqu'à tolérer
l'intolérance et si on ne défend pas
notre société très sale aux intolérants
elle pourrait tomber toute entière dans
l'intolérance et donc on détruirait la
tolérance l'histoire lui a donné raison
s'est un petit peu ce qui s'est passé
que le nazisme c'est très simple en
théorie mais beaucoup plus difficile en
pratique puisqu'on en train de
travailler sur des notions sont pas tout
à fait objectif quoi la frontière entre
le tolérer l'intolérance
elle n'est pas extrêmement nettes
je précise d'ailleurs petites précisions
sur ce que j'ai à dire sur poppers il
dit pas qu'il faut empêcher les
intervenants s'exprimer non il dit juste
que il faut revendiquer le droit de le
faire
pour ce qui est de comment être ouvert
d'esprit la réponse découle de ce qu'on
était plutôt en gros on a dit qu'il
avait un rejet car il y avait peur et
qu'il y avait peur car il y avait un
connu belle fille de résoudre cet aspect
non connu ça passe par se confronter à
cette inconnue justement ça peut être
fait de manière très simple comme
changer quelques habitudes de sortir de
sa zone de confort mais ça peut aussi ça
peut aussi se faire en se cultivant
discutant beaucoup avec ce que l'on
pourrait considérer comme différent et
en s'intéressant à leur vision des
choses
le voyage lire aussi ça peut grandement
aider parce que ça permet de vivre par
procuration des filles qui sont très
loin des nôtres et d'avoir une meilleure
compréhension de tous les angles fait
intéressant il ya une étude parue dans
le psychologique holtzheim ce qui
explique que non seulement notre langue
maternelle influence fortement notre
vision du monde
ce qui paraît extrêmement logique
d'ailleurs je fais forcément une vidéo
sur le langage même si je ne sais pas
encore sous quelle fin mais elle
explique aussi qu'à voir une seconde
langue permet d'avoir une vision
alternative du monde
donc forcément ça aide aussi à être plus
ouverts d'esprit
voilà j'espère que cet épisode vous a
plu si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à
partager poser aussi d'autres questions
sur twitter avec le hashtag accès aux
loges ou bien en commentaire de cette
vidéo et n'oublie pas que c'est ça paie
des questions sur la philo la psycho la
culture la science ou vraiment pas ça
d'un bel haji shah radès est aussi donc
je trouve ça vachement coach nous envoie
donc tu loeb et de la pisse ciao
si vous regardez cette vidéo avant mi
mai 2015 il y à une annonce importante à
la fin de la vidéo